mrs. Stuart wills with Sciences web and
you media editorial group today science
publishes a special issue on human
conflict and is as a tie-in to that
special issue we're very pleased today
to have three scientists to join us in a
panel discussion specifically about the
topic of ethnic conflict where it comes
from and perhaps what can be done about
it missouri and bonacci a psychologist
at harvard university has studied
individual innate human prejudice and
bias against out groups Deborah ray an
economist at New York University has
looked at regional intergroup conflict
through the lens of economics and
Richard Chris a social psychologist at
the University of Kent focuses on the
psychological dimensions of social
diversity and inter cultural contact
also on the line is science contributing
editor Elizabeth colada who reports on
the roots of racism in a story in the
special issue and Elizabeth maybe that's
a good place to start sort of the
individual level whether we're if you
will sort of hardwired for ethnic bias
thank you through so in this story I
wrote on the roots of racism my topic
Mazarin bana she and others about how
racism is really one aspect of a much
broader prejudice that might be
considered sort of in group love and
advocate mothering can talk to us a
little bit about those terms and what
they need sure and let me just start by
saying that we think that the in an
out-group pneus of our perceptions
really is part of the basic architecture
of our cognition most species of almost
any living organism needs to know the
difference between two sets of things in
their world so a Robin has just laid
eggs in a nest outside my front door and
for that Robin it's very important to
know the difference between another
Robin and an eagle and me
that's what it needs to know that's what
I as a human being need to know when I
navigate the social universe who are the
people like myself for the people a
little bit different from me and
sometimes those markings are visible and
very obvious so something like race is
an interesting example because of the
when we look at race if it's not I think
multiracial people are creating a little
bit of chaos for us because we can't
easily put people into these categories
that were used to but in general we're
good at knowing what sets of things are
tables and chairs but also Mormons and
Protestants Hutu and Tutsi black and
white and out of that come certain types
of feelings that at some default levels
seem to be more Pro the in group or more
pro people who are like ourselves now
that's that story is fairly robust it's
one of the most ubiquitous results in
psychology and Richard Chris can
actually tell you a lot about this is an
expert on questions of social identity
and this this particular kind of love
and hate for the in and the out group
and how easily it emerges in what are
called minimal groups so you don't even
have to tell somebody auto shows that
take these two big groups like for two
to three black white etc you can just
put people into a into two little rooms
and say you n das and they're the bees
and you can create something like in an
absolutist among people who are
relatively the same so it's a very
fundamental way in which we carve the
social problem modern is absolutely
right the it's incredibly easy in the
laboratory to create prejudice if you
like and the studies that she was
talking about by taxpayer and colleagues
in the nineteen seventies had a huge
impact that if they showed that in fact
that we quite shocking results at the
time that you can create essentially
precious dislike towards someone in
another group in laboratory when that
group was simply created out of
having a different color t-shirt or
being given away rather than the blue
pen or simply even by tossing a coin we
does seem to be this innate tendency for
us to like our in groups things which
are similar to us but to dislike will be
wary or be concerned about outreach then
people who are in someone classified as
different from us never and their get
hundreds of studies replicating this is
based in fact is that reasonable to say
that we are that we sort of see the
world of coalition's or we're ready to
see the world this way but that who the
in groups and out groups are can change
is that the idea yeah I would say that
that's a very good way to put it we have
some kind of a default ability to be
able to immediately look at who might be
part of the coalition that we belong to
and others but it changes and I'll give
you an example from a species where
these coalition's change quite a bit so
in some research that I did with Laurie
Santos it's her lab really that took the
lead on this project and I was a
collaborator but what we looked at were
rhesus monkeys who do end up having this
very interesting social feature that
male members of the group will often
leave one social group and move to
another so who used to be part of your
in group is now part of your elbow and
who used to be a part of your ad group
is now part of the in group and what we
can show is that that system is
malleable enough that they will treat a
member of the in group who is now an out
group as an out-group mapper they will
they will associate those folks more
with nasty things like spiders and
snakes rather than good things like
fruit and other positive say so this is
a nice little example of how how both
that there are coalition's and that they
are variable and malleable and so this
honestly has deep evolutionary roots if
I something like macaque feels this way
absolutely I think it has deep evolution
roots it also is hugely shaped by the
social circumstances in which we find
ourselves and so I would say it's that
it's putting the two side by side and
never assuming that it's the innate part
of it that's important or just that the
social learning where is important and
this is extremely difficult for most
ordinary human lives to do I mean most
of the readers of science magazine I
would venture don't even know that there
could be a science of something like
this okay but we can study at these from
a psychological point of view we can
study the mental mechanisms that kick in
and when we look at those mental
mechanisms we can see evidence both of
how deeply these are in US and how
ancient they must be we can see this by
looking at other species and comparing
them to us you can look at the behavior
of very young children we can look at
the behavior of infants and see that at
age three months they're already turning
in the direction of those voices or
those skin colors or are those genders
that are more familiar to them rather
than the less familiar and these are the
roots of what can eventually become
full-blown prejudice full glow ethnic
conflict and I think our science has
been very carefully lining what those
micro sort of groups of these eventual
ethnic conflicts are
you